oh hi i'm starting today detective
santiago oh
detective peralta welcome aboard i'm
hearing wedding bells hi detective boyle
i love these pills they give me so much
energy
and i can eat whatever i want
oh god
he's dead hey jenny
jake i don't want to go out anymore i
like any fun now
but it's my bar mitzvah we were gonna
grind
key it's over disco man
put down the yo-yo and back away from
the girl
[Music]
marco no you say polo
oak hey ames you're gonna spend the rest
of your life in a little cement room
doing nothing and while you're in there
i'm gonna go for a swim
and after that swim i might take another
swim and you'll just be sitting here
on your metal toilet thinking of me
swim swim swimming all
day long when i get out of lockup i'm
going to hunt you down
and kill you yeah
right i'll be coming back for you i'm
just like disco baby
i will never die true disco will never
die
but you will in your cell punk
looks like we both want that stapler
seems that way based on what happened
madeleine
[Music]
would you care for a drink i'd love one
i'm sure you can tell
i'm quite drunk i've had a couple to
build up the nerve
i think we both know what i'm about to
say
raymond i don't think we need to say
anything
i'm gay that's what i was going to tell
you
well then it was 1995.
i just made detectives i was really
excited about my first day at the 6'5
but the guys in the squad were a bunch
of jerks hi i'm terry
which desk is mine solve a case then you
get a desk
they were like that about a lot of stuff
whoa solve a case
then you get coffee
solve a case then you can sign debbie's
birthday card
sounds like you needed to solve a case
exactly so i picked the biggest one i
could find
a string of b and e's all with the same
m.o
guy climbed in through high-rise windows
after a month i found my suspect
dimitri kuzco an ex-acrobat with a
criminal record
circus trash it has to be him that's
exactly what i said
circus trash it has to be him i tracked
down my acrobat
got swat to surround his building there
was no way
anything could go wrong down get on the
ground
so two keys huh
that's a lot of snow if you can't handle
it we're happy to find someone who can't
don't worry about me friend i can handle
it
marissa baby go get our guests something
to drink would you we don't want a drink
or is this a social cup it's not a tea
party i look like five-year-old girls
too gentlemen please
have some patience cookies
pure as a catholic school girl did you
bring the cash
oh we brought something much better than
cash what's that our guns
nypd you're under arrest
[Music]
little lady
[Music]
gio costa you're under arrest you want
that drink now hitchcock don't mind if i
do scully
don't mind if i do
[Music]
you